the Wisconsin man accused of kidnapping
Jamie Clausen killing her parents is due
in court this morning Jake Patterson is
his name he faces two counts of first
degree intentional homicide one count of
kidnapping and one count of armed
burglary
Jamie was held captive for 88 days
before she managed to escape last month
Jamie yuccas has been speaking with the
13 year olds friends and family she's
outside Barron County Circuit Court in
Wisconsin Jamie good morning to you a
lot of people want to know how Jamie
Claus is doing good morning yes we know
that Gail today's preliminary hearing
though is to gauge the strength of the
prosecutors evidence some of Jamie Casas
loved ones are expected to be inside the
court later today and they do tell us
that Jamie is making steady progress in
her recovery people can buy the blue
bracelet and what do they say on him
it's amazing
Michelle Safford is friends with the
Klaus family she says since coming home
Jamie has been time with loved ones and
in therapy every single person I talked
to her just once Jamie to heal and be
able to move forward with her life do
you feel like that's happening I do I
don't think any of us can really know
what she's going through but I think
that if she has to be with a group of
people that will love her and support
her for the rest of her life she's in
the perfect family to do that this week
the Klaus family released this picture
of the 13 year old enjoying a steak
dinner with her grandfather
today Jamie's alleged kidnapper 21 year
old Jake Patterson will face a judge in
person for the first time we've never
talked about him or any of that kind of
stuff and I hope we never have to
investigators revealed last week they
had obtained call logs photos and videos
from Patterson's cellphone which was in
the front seat of his car when he was
arrested according to the criminal
complaint
Patterson shot and killed Jamie's
parents in October as they tried to
protect her he allegedly confessed to
targeting the teenager after seeing her
getting on a school bus he's accused of
holding her captive in his house until
she broke free nearly three months later
Jamie's cousin and two of her aunts
spoke to Gail King shortly after they
were reunite
with her if you wanted Jamie why would
you go at that time a night and kill the
parents right it I mean nothing made
sense I'm sure you all have racked your
brains about it did anybody know this
guy yeah yeah there's no I know that
makes you wonder if Jamie won't have
been so courageous to get away that day
what what what happened
Charlie Glynn and Richard Jones are
Patterson's public defenders when you
have a confession like this how much
harder is your case well these cases by
their nature are very very difficult
cases we have responsibility to review
everything we have to conduct our own
investigation
Safford says no matter what happens with
the suspect Jamie will be okay I have no
doubt that she's gonna make it I have no
doubt in my mind at all strong little
fighter she is the question before the
judge today as if there's enough
evidence to proceed with the trial Jake
Patterson is not expected at this point
to enter a plea he is being held on five
million dollars bail fionna we are all
thinking and pulling for Jamie Jamie
thank you yeah